And then in the next scene you see this
model home up for destruction.
It's quite an interesting scene.
Symbolically.
See
in the middle of this house here,
there's a stain glass window that has a
Mandela on it.
We'll we'll see it more clearly in a
minute.
And amended.
Mandela is a sacred symbol of the self.
That's,
that's the union interpretation.
It's a symbol.
It's very difficult to describe,
but it's a symbol.
Music is a Mandela except it's played
out across time.
So you could say that that thing is the
same as music,
but it's Kinda like a slice of music.
It's,
it's,
it's the same idea.
You know,
sometimes you see those slow motion or
sped up motion videos of a flower
unfolding that's the same.
It's the same idea.
You can imagine that being set to music
and somehow that would make sense that
Mandela is like a symbol of the
unfolding of being and,
or the source of meaning or something
like that.
And it's also a symbol of the self.
I'm from the union perspective.
And so there you see it more clearly.
Kids are starting to burn this place.
And,
and trash it,
and they're dragging the grand piano
down the down the stairs,
uh,
the destruction of high culture about
which they're nothing but cynical
because they don't believe that hard
work and sacrifice can,
can produce something of any value and
they want to bring it down and destroy
it.
And that's partly because
can see this in the story of Cain and
Abel.
Table is hard working and everyone likes
him and he makes the proper sacrifices.
And so his life goes really well.
And that's part of the reason that cain
hates him and he's jealous and
resentful.
But worse than that,
if you're around someone,
if you're not doing very well,
especially if that's your own fault.
If you're not doing very well and you're
around someone who's doing very well,
it's very painful because the mere fact
of there being judges you.
And so it's very easy to want to destroy
that,
to destroy that ideal so that you don't
have to live with the terrible
consequences of seeing it embodied in
front of you.
And so part of the reason that people
want to tear things down is so that they
don't have anything to contrast
themselves against and to feel bad.
And that's exactly what's happening
here.
The kids are destroying all of this
culture,
roughly speaking because it judges them
the fact that it exists,
judges them.
And I've often thought this about
Michelangelo Statue of David,
which is this heroic.
So David was a shepherd obviously,
and it doesn't sound like much,
but back in those times being a shepherd
was a big deal because there were lions
and you had a slingshot.
And so like you got to defend your sheep
from lions with a slingshot.
So you weren't exactly this,
like 19th century English guy dressed in
a fairly blue suit.
You were tough as a bloody.
Well,
it's someone who would go after lion
with a slingshot.
It's no joke.
Anyways,
the statue is very heroic and you know,
you look at that,
you think,
well,
the possibility of,
of human kind.
But by the same token,
it's also what you're not.
And so as well as being an ideal,
it's a judge.
And every ideal is a judge,
so yes.
Yup.
So you're,
you're using that as an example to
illustrate the coming fitter as a result
of not being
able to achieve a status as a result,
as a result of hard work.
But in the example of Canaan,
April.
Yeah.
I'm like one was a shepherd and the
other was a farmer.
And the one who knows no one is.
Yes,
that's right.
What was the shepherd was the one who
was favorite?
Yes,
that's right.
Was that a result of the hard work or
was that a result of good question?
The stories as well.
That's a good question.
Those stories are very,
very complicated and the story is very
ambivalent about whether Kane is not
rewarded because he makes bad sacrifices
or because God's just in a bad mood and
that I like that.
If you read the story,
I've read multiple translations of the
story and when,
when caden comes to God,
wait,
God basically tells him,
look,
buddy,
before you go about criticizing the
structure of reality,
you should look to your own
inadequacies.
He says,
Sin Crouches at your door like a
predatory sexually aroused animal and
you invited it in to have its way with
you and something has emerged as a
consequence.
So p bothered me about my creation
before you look to yourself,
so there's a very strong hint that the
reason that God has not favor cane
sacrifices because they weren't
particularly good quality,
so but the but it is ambivalent in the
story and there is the shepherd versus
farmer Motif as well and of course that
motif runs through the whole entire
corpus of stories to some degree,
especially the shepherd motif.
So it's only about a paragraph long.
That whole story and it packs all that
into that tiny little amount of space.
But the idea that cain kills able to get
rid of is ideal and also to punish God.
Roughly speaking.
It's a brilliant story.
I mean these guys who go around shooting
up high schools are shooting up high
schools in particular,
but you know there are definitely out
for revenge and what their revenging
themselves against or to who is not
exactly clear.
Anyways,
so these kids are just tearing down this
model home carrying down Western
civilization.
I suppose it's another way of looking at
or just tearing down civilization period
and Pinocchio's having a pretty good
time.
He's got his ax and he's looking a
little malevolent there and,
and happy to be destroying things,
which is of course a pretty simple thing
to do.
So there's that image that I told you
about the Mandela that's a flower in
this image.
And so what happens is that,
uh,
I think it's lamp wick throws a brick
through it.
And so what that means is this the self
as a symbol of your potential among very
many other things,
but by engaging in this sort of
impulsive,
destructive activity,
lamp,
Wick and Pinocchio,
or making it impossible for them to
further their development.
And they're doing that to some degree
consciously,
you know,
they basically say to hell with it and
toss a brick through this highest ideal,
the thing through which light shines.
So also that hearkens back to the,
to the stars.
Well,
so.